this keyboard puzzle concept allows you
to rearrange the keys in any layout you
prefer and Carnegie Mellon is building a
robotic chimp that turns into a tank
Vsauce Kevin here
this is Milo
an engineering professor at the
University of Michigan is developing a
remote object detection system that
could quickly scan for guns in schools
airports stadiums and malls use Doppler
radar and particular millimeter
wavelength to create what they call the
DNA of walking which clearly
differentiates a human based on their
frequency response and radar polarimetry
which measures and interprets
electromagnetic waves basically the
visual response of someone carrying a
metal object like a gun is noticeable
and then they can be flagged and perhaps
further investigated the major benefit
being that not only could this system
very quickly scan large numbers of
people but also from a distance as far
away as a hundred yards but ultimately
there's still a lot more research that
would need to go into something like
this researchers at Hewlett Packard Labs
have created glasses-free 3d displays
for mobile devices
it works with a backlight and a light
scattering material that sends light
rays in specific directions so that the
image can be seen at different angles
depending on how you look at it but
apparently this technology won't be
available to the public anytime soon
world's largest sweater rope it's is a
transport robot that drives itself after
you pick a destination on your
smartphone the robot for personal
intelligent transport system was created
by Hitachi and travels at three point
seven miles per hour
it also features a stereo camera and
laser rangefinders to avoid collisions
and it's aimed at helping people who
need assistance / to get around the city
Zoe is a digital talking head that can
express a range of human emotions
developed at Cambridge University the
system works by typing in text and
choosing different degrees of an emotion
don't forget mom's birthday have you got
a gift yet it was built by having an
actress say 7,000 sample sentences in
different emotions and capturing all of
the movements the pH conditioner is a
concept where giant jellyfish structures
clean polluted air an honorable mention
at the 2013 skyscraper competition the
idea is for these robotic jellyfish to
float 600 feet in the air and filter
China's polluted air by capturing acidic
fog and purifying the sheep head fish is
a fish and
human teeth the salamander robotic a2 is
the only robot able to swim crawl and
walk its locomotion is controlled by
neural circuits along its spinal cord
and a remote computer triggers
electrical signals that mimic those from
a real salamanders brain and it's being
used not only to better understand
locomotion systems but to potentially
developed new search-and-rescue tools
sim sensei is a virtual therapist the
USC Institute for Creative Technologies
is bringing together clinical psychology
cognitive science computer vision speech
processing and artificial intelligence
to create this multi sent system that
analyzes facial expressions body posture
and even notices if you're fidgeting
they say it's not designed for therapy
or medical diagnosis just as a tool for
health care providers so how are you
doing today
I'm doing well that's good
finally Swiss designer Paul Braun Bakker
says there's nothing to do in the winter
so he creates these incredible
hand-cranked marble machines
you
I'm going to leave you with the
radio-controlled copters a Tesla coil
and as always thanks for watching
how's the game going
[ __ ] should you be doing game loot